right here moment with reaction is
Judiciary Committee chairman Jim Jordan
a prop Jim is Hank Johnson at the
unmitigated Gall to call uh this
wonderful woman who lost her son wow
Miss brame is not a prop she's not a
stunt she's a mom on a mission and I
learned a long time ago that Mom's on a
mission beat politicians every single
time and she showed that today I would
say this song the witnesses we had today
were some of the most my time in
Congress some of the most compelling
Witnesses we have ever had we had a dad
whose son was attacked we had Miss frame
we had the Democrat city council member
who's lived in his whole life 71 years
in the city and said he's never seen it
this bad so yeah these weren't props
these weren't stunts these were people
telling their story they're not into
politics they just want a D.A who's not
soft on crime they want Safe Streets
they want a Subway they can ride and
this is happening all across the country
27 of the 30 most dangerous cities are
run by democrats where they typically
have a D.A like Mr Bragg who's soft on
crime this is why the New York Post said
it was good that we came to town put a
national Spotlight on this because
that's always the first step in stopping
this ridiculous treatment that is
happening in so many of our urban areas
you know Congressman I'm glad you came
to New York and I'm I'm glad the
Democrats expose themselves here I said
this earlier since 2009 Congressman you
know you watch this show I scroll the
names names Americans never heard of all
the people shot shot and killed in
Chicago nobody how come we never hear
about those names you can predict On Any
Given weekend how many people are going
to be shot in that hellhole of a city
and then shot and killed and probably be
pretty accurate you know what and nobody
that's a democratic-run city for decades
Democratic state for decades and
nobody's lifted a finger to save the
lives of innocent children now in New
York City there was one mayor he took a
lot of crap for it but he saved a lot of
lives and including a lot of minority
lives his name was Rudy Giuliani
[Applause]
yeah and it's but it's it's also bigger
than the violence sometimes it's just
the theft there were 327 individuals
responsible for 6 000 of the thefts in
New York City I mean think about that
that's 20 per person and in fact we used
to call that stealing taking someone
else's property if you don't have a
deterrent if you don't put some of those
people away if you don't charge those
people prosecute those people they just
keep doing it so do it after one two
three do it after 19 times but for some
for for goodness sake stop it somewhere
that's the kind of stuff that's going on
and what is Alvin Bragg doing instead of
dealing with this kind of criminal
activity he's using federal funds to
indict a former president for no crime
and then when we want to investigate
that and do our constitutional Duty and
talk to a guy who hasn't worked to him
for a year he takes us to court that's
what we were highlighting today just how
serious the crime problem the real crime
problem is in New York City well said uh
Congressman Jim Jordan the great state
of Ohio Madeline again thank you so much
God bless you praying for you okay hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else